هل هو سلب لحريه الراي ام حمايه لنزاهه
الانتخابات تويتر يفاجئ المستخدمين في
تركيا باعلانه منع وصولهم لبعض المحتوى
بحجه الالتزام بالاجراءات القانونيه
الاعلان هذا اقتصر على يوم واحد بحسب
التويتر ولم يفصح عن نوعيه الحسابات او
التغريدات التي منع الوصول اليها الا ان
الاجراء عرض ملكه تويتر ايلون ماسك
للانتقادات وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست وهناك
من اعتبره تقييدا لحريه التعبير خاصه بعد
ان اتخذت الحكومه التركيه اجراء مشابها
بمنع الوصول لمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
فبراير الماضي حينما هز الزلزال ارجاء
الدوله وعندما وجه صحفيون امريكيون
الاتهام لماسك جاءه الرد سريعا ليقول اما
تقييد جزئي للمحتوى او حظر كل يوم للتطبيق
ايهما ستختار